Identify complementary and supplementary
angles in the image below. So just as a reminder
complementary angles are two angles
that add up to 90 degrees and
supplementary angles, supplementary angles add up to
180 degrees.  So let's look at this diagram.
First let's look for the complementary,
complementary angles. So angles that add up to 90 degrees and so they drew this right angle right over here.
So we know that angle FAH
is a right angle, because they did this little
half box right over there,
and it's made up of two adjacent angles
and these two adjacent angles make up a 90 degree angle so they must add up to 90 degrees.
so the two angles-- angle FAC
Angle FAC
and Angle
CAH and
Angle CAH, let me do it in a different color since I already used that) and angle CAH and
Angle CAH are
complementary because the measures of these two angles
must add up to 180 degrees are-- sorry, must add up to this 90 degrees right over here.
And I think that's all the complementary angles.
Just these two, they add up to this
right angle, to this 90 degrees.
Now let's think about the supplementary angles, so
supplementary,
supplementary angles.  They add up to 180 degrees.
So you have angle FAC, or we could call it CAF.
It's the same angle. So angle CAF,
and then this angle out here, FAB.
When they're adjacent to each other
and they clearly form a straight angle
which is 180 degrees
when you add their two measures.
So these two are clearly
supplementary and
angle FAB.   FAB.
CAF and FAB together definitely add up to 180 degrees
so they're supplementary.  And then the other one--
we can do angle CAH,
angle CAH,
which is this right over here,
that plus HAB clearly add up.
They form-- They're adjacent.
They form a straight angle.
So they are clearly adding up to 180 degrees.
So they are also supplementary.
CAH and
angle HAB.
And we're done.
These two angles add up to 90.
These two add up to 180,
these two add up to 180.